réfléchis pas
[Musique]
je fais le tour
on va descendre le relief va perturber
sa conduite de dire
et reviens
parle-moi Mister
[Musique]
et je tire
plus de missile je passe au canon
c'est pas fini
j'ai branché la radio magnifique
contacte le porte-avion reçu
[Musique]
et oui
on a plus de larmes
il est déjà sur nous
[Musique]
non non non
on s'aimera pas il faut s'éjecter il
faut remonter tire sur les poignées
d'éjection quand je te le dirai non
attends on n'a pas le choix
éjection éjection éjection
les poignées et j'ai chaud
[Musique]
je suis désolé
mesdames et messieurs bonjour c'est
votre Sauveur qui vous parle veuillez
attachez vos ceintures relevez et
bloquez vos tablettes en position
verticale
et tenez-vous prêt pour l'atterrissage
salut à au top je suis au top ruster au
top du top
on se retrouve sur le pont
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
est dans le 8 miracle numéro 2 reste
Coffin corner
c'est parti
situation
[Musique]
déploiement contre le
je suis pas toucher
droit devant
[Musique]
j'ai pas vu de parachute qu'il faut
qu'on y retourne